i
[Música]
hasta ahora unos 8000 personas aún
continúan en los albergues tras el paso
de los huracanes yo está dieta en
nicaragua en su momento fueron 160.000
personas desplazadas según los datos
oficiales pero estas han comenzado a
retornar a sus hogares de forma segura
el plan de reconstrucción ha iniciado
las zonas más devastadas según el
gobierno hasta ahora ha entregado unas
260.000 láminas de zinc así como cocinas
frazadas colchonetas y unos 100.000
bonos productivos para garantizar la
seguridad alimentaria los servicios
básicos se han restablecido en un 95 por
ciento en todo el territorio nacional a
nivel económico la pandemia de
coronavirus y el paso de estos dos
huracanes de forma continua podrían
representar un respiro para la economía
y especialmente para el gobierno de
daniel ortega quien se espera recibe en
los próximos días en concepto de
préstamos y otros ingresos un aproximado
de 500 millones de dólares aunque no
todos serán manejados de forma directa
debido a las sanciones internacionales
[Música]
el paso de los huracanes y
posteriormente convertidos en tormenta
tropical está ello está en honduras
dejaron más de 4 millones de personas
afectadas y más de 100 muertos según
estimaciones del comité de contingencias
los daños a la economía no se han podido
cuantificar ya que miles de hectáreas de
cultivo de granos básicos palma africana
y banano se encuentran completamente
inundados también el daño a la
infraestructura es de proporciones muy
grandes miles de carreteras fueron
destruidas fuentes y también el
principal aeropuerto de san pedro sula
en este momento el gobierno ha lanzado
un oeste oeste al mundo para iniciar un
plan de reconstrucción y ya atendieron
este llamado varios organismos
internacionales como el banco
interamericano de desarrollo el banco
centroamericano de integración económica
y el banco mundial muchos países también
han enviado ayudas humanitarias que
consiste en alimentación ropa y muchas
contingentes de médicos y cuerpos de
socorro
[Música]
j fue el huracán más fuerte que haya
recibido colombia nunca afectando
especialmente a las islas de san andrés
providencia y santa catalina el 98 por
ciento de la infraestructura de la isla
de providencia quedó devastada y al
menos dos personas en los archipiélagos
han muerto las 16 horas en las que
providencia estuvo incomunicada hicieron
temer que la desgracia fuese aún mayor
sin embargo la evaluación de daños
continua además de miles de casas
destruidas se han perdido miles de
árboles y un 17% de especies de fauna y
flora presenta una gran amenaza muchos
advierten por ejemplo que las iguanas no
tienen árboles en los que apoyarse el
gobierno ya está en plena remoción de
escombros y ha entregado ayuda
humanitaria a los habitantes que además
han prometido construir 1200 viviendas
nuevas así como la reconstrucción del
acueducto el alcantarillado y las
comunicaciones también están surgiendo
distintas iniciativas de reconstrucción
con donaciones privadas como providencia
de renace que trata de encontrar fondos
para reconstruir una isla con viviendas
que soporten futuros ataques de la
naturaleza pero que sean respetuosas con
la cultura raíz a la autóctona de las
islas
[Música]